the OverWatch League could have been the
crown jewel of Esports with lofty dreams
and expectations but now the reality is
that the League's teams are allegedly
lowering up to start a collective
bargaining process against Activision
Blizzard now why would the teams need to
do this and is this the beginning of the
end for the OverWatch League
hey everyone just a quick reminder that
we have merch available I know
Valentine's Day is coming up so you
might want to get something for that
special someone or if you're like me
alone for yourself a single people I
don't know if we'll ever find someone
but at least we can get a nice
sweatshirt Activision Blizzard OverWatch
and trouble three words that never seem
to be able to be separated from one
another and the latest owl news is no
exception according to report by Jacob
wolf a majority of teams in the owl have
retained British Law Firm sheridans to
quote start a collective bargaining
process against the league after years
of high operating costs and continually
missed promises on Revenue to put this
in simple terms apparently a lot of your
favorite overall teams are lawyering up
because they want some sort of
compensation after what they believe are
years of high investment with inadequate
returns in both support he says the aim
of the discussions is to quote for the
teams to be awarded some sort of
economic relief to promote
sustainability after each franchise
spent somewhere between 7.5 to 10
million dollars in franchise payments
over the past six years as well as more
than one million dollars in operating
costs each year to maintain their teams
and that's not to mention the reported
20 million dollars teams had to pay to
secure an OverWatch League's franchise
law in season one with a further 30 to
60 million dollars for season two just
think about the operating costs of a
team of course you have to pay your
players but then you also pay your
coaches analysts team managers social
media managers content people etc etc
there's a lot more that goes into a team
than just your favorite DPS player wolf
reported that the decision to
collectively organize was in part led by
overactive media the group that owns the
Toronto defiant when the score Esports
reached out to them to confirm the
validity of the report a spokesperson
for overactive media said the teams in
the league are Partners we have always
worked together and continue to do so we
have a collective interest in the
OverWatch league and its success nothing
material has changed on this front we
also reached out for comment from
Sheridan's Law Firm allegedly
representing these teams but the time of
publishing we have not heard back so it
looks like a lot of the owl teams are in
a bad spot and to understand maybe how
they got out there we gotta go back to
the Inception of the league apparently
like we said earlier the price tag to
join the OverWatch League was massive
but eventually organizations did cough
the cash needed to create your favorite
teams like the Toronto defiant Florida
Mayhem San Fran shock Etc Cloud9 CEO
Jack said about joining the OverWatch
League that he asks to be a part of the
OverWatch League are large there's a big
commitment in getting through the door
people are scared of change and
intimidated to take the risk into
getting something new While others are
scared I'm going to be moving forward
into something I think is the evolution
of Esports that's when cloud9's
approached since day one the monetary
risks that Jack was willing to take was
to evolve Esports into a new meta AKA
actic hint traditional Sports the
Tactical the OverWatch League was to be
as big as possible and key wording here
be sustainable comparison to the
National Football League were thrown
around all of this to say that people
and organizations were pouring money
into this league and it wasn't for no
reason it was reported that Activision
Blizzard showed potential buyers that
the League's projected Revenue would be
22 million by 2018 50 million in 2019
and then 120 25 million in 2020. the owl
was a hell of ambitious Venture it was a
dream to realize what Esports could be
it was clear it was supposed to be the
Titan of the industry the Giant in this
space but just because it was ambitious
does not mean it was guaranteed while
season one of the owl was promising by
apparently exceeding the 22 million
dollars and rejected Revenue
expectations after that was a very Rocky
Road the League's Revenue did not live
up to the projections according to a
Bloomberg article teams struggled to
make money on their own butts were not
being put into seats and fans weren't
into buying merge concessions Etc
allegedly Activision Blizzard would hand
out free tickets to students or bus
employees to the Blizzard arena in
Burbank California if CEO Bobby cottek
or any other VIPs were coming to see a
game reportedly the owl seemed to rely
heavily on Bobby kodek's vision and
support and apparently that support
began to dwindle over time until
Microsoft's attempted purchase of
Activision Blizzard a 69 billion dollar
deal which the FDC is currently trying
to block then when the covered pandemic
started in 2020 well apparently some
teams said the lack of Live Events was
better for their wallet Activision
Blizzard reportedly allowed teams to
push off payments of fees as well as
awarding teams two million dollars with
the agreement that the teams would not
sue the company in March 2021 Activision
Blizzard laid off employees who were
part of the Esports and quote other Live
Events with the company saying players
are increasingly choosing to connect
with our games digitally and the Esports
team much like traditional Sports
entertainment and broadcasting
Industries has had to adopt its business
due to the impact the pandemic has had
on Live Events a little aside layoffs
were not and are not uncommon just this
week of writing Microsoft announced are
going to lay off about 10 000 employees
and apparently Rye games laid off an
unknown number while they aren't
uncommon layoffs can be an indicator of
an institution's poor economic health
and then later in 2021 as I'm sure we
all know the harassment lawsuit Saga
began the California Department of Fair
Employment and housing sued Activision
Blizzard for alleged widespread
harassment and discrimination of female
employees at the company this led to
sponsors of the OverWatch League like
Coca-Cola T-Mobile and State Farm to
reassess their position as of March 2022
this is apparently not a single visible
sponsor for the league and I cannot find
any mention of one on the official
website and we are now entering an era
in which crypto is no longer seemingly
viable and venture capital investment in
Esports is the lowest it has ever been
since 2016. apart from 2020. no brand
interest is coupled with a dipping
popular interest the owl continues to
Trend downwards in terms of viewership
as Francisco Caruso writes the league is
losing popularity around the world
something we can see from the fall
popularity of the regional broadcasts
the OverWatch League definitely needs to
reinvent itself it doesn't help that
after twitch paid 90 million dollars for
exclusive streaming rights a deal was
made to exclusively broadcast the owl on
YouTube while the deal made Activision
Blizzard reportedly 160 million dollars
the move is criticized and viewership
declined all of this leads us right back
to the original Jacob wolfipur it is
clear the owl was not the success it was
made out to be so now you have teams
pushing against Activision Blizzard
saying what are you going to do do about
this apparently for them they've
invested tens of millions into a vision
that they were sold on but that Vision
has not come true now apparently some of
them are operating at a loss perhaps
Activision Blizzard had been more
realistic with their projections and
desires for the league design and
infrastructure this all could have been
avoided as well bettingfield wrote for
Wired Esports isn't dying investors are
now in the reality of the consequence
for being sold on quote wildly
exaggerated expectations it was only a
few days ago that Arnold her CEO of gen
G the parent company of Seoul Dynasty
said I've been saying the Esports winter
is coming but even I didn't think it
would be this cold now I've changed my
forecast and think 30 of Esports teams
worldwide won't make it in the next two
years while he is speaking in the
context of the lck his broader point of
the Esports ecosystem is entirely
applicable to the owl the owl will never
be what Bobby Cottage apparently dreamed
it would be now the league has to deal
with the reality of its own teams
apparently deciding to collectively
bargain against it
and continually missed promises on
Revenue
we're doing a train section can you even
hear the train Colton
can you let me know
because I feel like I'm gaslighting
myself in the entire company because I'm
like oh there's a train coming it's
definitely being picked up by the mic
but then sometimes I listen back I'm
like is it